I think it's important for us have good
relations with our closer Sun I think
it's important for our allies to be here
to commemorate the 70th anniversary of
the d-day landings have good relations
with the USA but I don't think we should
be rolling at the red carpet I don't
think this should be a state visit and
why do I say that
I think our closest allies akin to the
best friend and the thing about best
friend is of course you stand shoulder
to shoulder with them at times of
adversity but you've got to call them
out when you think they're wrong and
there are so many things about President
Donald Trump's policies that the
antithesis of our values in London but
also our values as a country but you see
no distinction then between between the
office of the president and the occupant
of that office I mean if there isn't a
time to roll out the red carpet for the
United States president surely you know
the commemorations that he is attending
surely that is the occasion on which he
should know there are other close allies
coming for the commemorations there not
go in a state visit a state banquet cost
in millions of pounds and my point is
this some of the things on Amazon over
the last two three years Londoners find
abhorrent and offensive rolling back the
reproductive rights of women separating
children from their parents on the
Mexican border introduced a ban on
Muslim majority countries standing up
and defending white supremacist neo
Nazis and I'd to see mites in
charlottesville amplifying messages from
racists in this country walking away
from the Paris climate Accord and I
could go on and buy frustration with our
prime minister is she's not willing to
say boo to a goose what do you think he
would do to the nominally special
relationship for Donald Trump to be told
that the red carpet wouldn't be ruled a
well no there's no reason at all are we
kind of good relations with the USA look
we in London benefit from massive
investment to our city from US companies
you as individuals we have this summer
great American sports come into London
with major league baseball and I love
Americans and many Americans love our
city in our country but that friendship
means candle
and I think we should be candid with the
America the American president sail you
know what we disagree you and so many
thing
that doesn't mean we can't still have a
good relationship we go distinguish the
current office holder of the president
of the USA and our relationship with the
country and its people and its
businesses and future office holders we
now know that I Prime Minister won't be
around for much longer similarly this
president won't be there forever and one
of the things that people look back on
about our approach to this president is
the well I think they'll regret that our
government this Prime Minister didn't
stand up more to him given your obvious
antipathy towards the man and given the
antipathy that you displayed on behalf
of those Londoners who you assume
dislike him there's a bit fully major
protests taking place on Tuesday can we
expect to see you at the front of it so
are we gonna the process I think that
it's inappropriate what's important
there any protest is peaceful lawful and
safe one of the things actually been
trying to hear that the Allies fall for
in the Second World War for us to have
these freedoms and these liberties to
protest against things that we find
objectionable I think it's right and
proper that Londoners and those who run
the country who what concerns around
Donald Trump should protest the key
thing is going to be lawful it's got to
be safe and it should be peaceful as
well do you have the money to police the
protest a lot the Met Police Service
would credibly hard I spoke to the
Commissioner I speaking to a regular
basis she's confident that the Met
Police Service were able to police our
city safely over the course of the next
few days of the president's visit and
also keep them safe as or which is
really important it's clear that there
have been some pressures placed on the
police you know and to a large extent
and those from the extinction rebellion
campaign a police officers working
crowby hard they are overstretched and
under-resourced that's a consequence of
massive cuts from this government over
the last eight nine years and you speak
to please and crime commissioners you
speak to chief constables around the
country they have similar challenges
there let's be clear you're not saying
that there's nothing you can do mean you
certain an 18 billion pound budget
that's were the reasons why and like the
previous mayor in my first three years
as men I've increased the record sums
the amount of monies that we give from
City Hall to the police through increase
in council tax through efficiencies to
through business rates by the way you
sure it's more like a finger in the dike
well the way funding works in this
country's
80% roughly speaking of funding for
police forces come
from central government in London were
losing a billion pounds and billion
pounds of funding from 2010 until 2020
so you can't escape the fact that police
officer numbers have gone down Q bhp
officer numbers have gone down please
staff has gone down police stations have
closed down and we're seeing the
consequences of massive cuts in policing
with the rise in violent crime okay
let's let's be explicit about this
burglary up 37 percent since she became
a robbery up 59 percent knife crime up
52 percent there have been goodness only
knows how many stories of young people
being stabbed on the streets there is a
direct line in your mind between the Rif
drawl of that billion pounds worth of
funding and those kids being stabbed
there is a link it's not the only reason
the causes of violent crime are complex
they're deep soil problems for excusing
criminality social alienation
inequalities a poverty lack of
opportunity lack of aspiration there is
also as part of that mix a consequence
of making massive cuts in the police
budget okay to what extent then is it a
matter of personal for regret a personal
regret for you that London is less safe
than when you took the job oh it's not
let's say that's the first thing we've
made huge progress in the last three
years but it's deeply upsetting to me
when I meet a bereaved mum or dad when I
meet a brother or sister whose life's
been changed forever because some of
their families lost their lives to
violent crime each death is a tragedy
you know I've been to too many funerals
and I've met too many Londoners whose
life will will never be the same again
and I think all these deaths that caused
by violent crime are preventable I think
had we invested in some of these young
Londoners at an earlier stage they could
have been diverted away from a crime
there's no excuse by the way for be
before somebody starving somebody many
of the victims are people who were in
the wrong place at the wrong time I
wonder if we can turn tipped into bricks
and and first of all though it does
European elections labour lost ground
hidden London rather shockingly in fact
many people that followed labour spread
fortunes here over the years is it that
equivocation over the second vote that
cost labour so badly it was
heartbreaking to speak to labour
supporters labor activists and labour
members who couldn't vote labor in the
European elections some of the reasons
we were given was the lack of clarity
around Labor's position around brexit
some of the reasons were given a lack of
being stronger about the fact that we've
been betrayed by those who made promises
to leave and we should be calling for a
a public vote and there is a real
concern that I've got that unless we
clarify at a national level our position
on where we stand in the European Union
it could lead to these people who didn't
vote first in the European elections not
voting for us the next time as an
election I mean let's be clear I mean
the second referendum was clearly an
issue perhaps as much of an issue is the
person that's leading the party surely
generally thought oh a big issue was the
lack of clarity in a position on your
Europe a big issue was the fact that
were not being stronger in relation to
the need for a public vote my views
quite clear my view is that what were
being presented with now from the
government is a million miles away from
Orr's promised in the referendum
campaign in light of that the British
public for the first time should give us
aid you accept this deal negotiate by
the government with the option of
remaining in the EU I mean the Labour
Party is it everyone would admit in
something of an invidious position you
know you've got the lead voters and the
northern the remain voters in the south
is there a way to square the circle you
know sometimes leadership is about
leading from the front you want to make
sure that people follow you but you've
got to be authentic and have conviction
in what you believe in we now know that
parliaments in gridlock Parliament can't
decide what is the optimum optimum
outcome now actually there's a pragmatic
case now for saying there should be
public votes so not just because you're
a conviction politician but for
pragmatic reasons give the British
public you say for the first time do you
want a stay in the European as imperfect
as it is reform it if you can or do you
accept the deal negotiated by the
government that will lead to by the way
less jobs less wealth that's prosperity
we already see in a consequence on the
NHS and in construction and other
sectors that's before we've got the
European Union I suppose I said pretty
quickly just check you did vote Labour I
don't have a good good we can move on
from there
Oh in all seriousness where does the Lib
party go with all the lack of electoral
success that it has had under jeremy
corbyn's
where does it go with him at the top of
the party jeremy corbyn's leader of our
party is one not one but two elections
to be the leader he's got my full
support I think those are the only
elections that he has won well I mean to
be fair the last time I do election was
called Teresa may concern' leader was 20
points ahead in the polls the only
reason why she called the general
election was to try and wipe out labour
and to win a massive majority so she
could negotiate an extreme brexit deal
with the European Union and Jeremy
Corbyn showed his abilities to campaign
I'm disappointed we didn't win the last
owner election but I'm confident there
if we stay united and we have a good
manifesto we can win and that means by
the way making sure we're clear in
relation to our views in the European
Union I wonder to what extent do you
think that being mayor of London sets
one up to be a prime minister of the
united kingdom now listen I'm loved I'm
loving being a Marilyn I love this city
looking forward to my next two three
four terms I'm perhaps thinking of the
maybe the chap that came before you
whether or not Boris Johnson you feel
that his time here at City Hall perhaps
made him I don't know a little bit more
practical a little more closer to the
numbers is there anything that he took
from his time here at City Hall that you
could see translating well in two days I
spent my first three years as mayor
spending too much time cleaning up his
mess the idea that Boris Johnson's
record as mayor is an application for
the job of being Prime Minister I find
astonishing what I can say is I'm
concerned that an ex Prime Minister will
be chosen by a small percentage of the
population something like 0.15 percent
of a country's population will choose
the next prime minister we should have a
conservative leader who understands the
need for a general election so the
British public can decide whether they
accept the verdict of a hundred thousand
Tory members or whether they want to
have a say and decide to rubber stamp
that person as the prime minister or to
give us a chance the Labour Party to
offer our country our manifesto our
offer for the future city can't thanks
very much for being with us